let go here newadvent.org
thank the Lord for internet all you do
is pay for the internet all these free
resources that the early Christians did
not have and yet they knew the Bible
better than you and I because they
memorized the Bible and they try to live
it out May the same holy spirit that
filled the holy Prophets The Holy
Apostles the Blessed Virgin the early
Christians fill us to love Jesus the way
they did and not for the praise of men
and may Spirit never allow us to
prostitute ourselves for status money
position and never allow us to betray or
deny or blasphemy the Lord Jesus Christ
and destroy all idolatry and blasphemy
from us and glorify the Lord Jesus even
unto death please holy spirit so so
there's the link you can go watch it now
here's
why
why we do the Lord's Prayer when we
begin let me show you one of the most
important documents preserved by the
grace of Lord Jesus Christ the D the the
D the internal evidence
demonstrates this was written in the
first century let me give you a little
history on here here's the link the
did it's a short read you can read it in
an hour you can read it in an hour the
right so we're going to get into the med
matter you're going to learn a lot
you'll be blown away tonight by the
power of the Holy Spirit working through
me the diday Let Me Explain the history
the evidence shows this is written in
the first century around 70 AD now here
it says 100 AD but no the evidence
shows 70 AD and there are even some who
think it was written around 50 ad the
internal evidence shows this document
was written during the time when the
apostles were still around because if
it's written 70 AD many of the apostles
were alive like John if it's written 50
ad Peter and Paul would have been around
you know why that's important if you're
listening do you know why that's
important if you're listening and not
being
distracted why that's
important do you understand why this is
important that if do this document is
written in the lifetime of the
Apostles let's say 50 ad or 70 AD John
definitely still alive anyone tell me
why that's
important
anybody because it's written to the
churches of the Apostles to the churches
of the
Apostles when the apostles are still
alive right to the churches of the
alive right the apostles are still
alive which means this is written with
their
approval with their blessing and their
acceptance so number one it's written to
the churches of the Apostles during the
time of the Apostles with the apostles
approval number two two it is a
manual on what they call orthopraxy
listen
orthopraxy there are two words you need
to learn Orthodoxy orthopraxy Orthodoxy
means correct sound Doctrine orthoprax
proxy means correct sound living
practice proxy practice the book is
about sound correct living it's not a
book about Doctrine it is a book
exhorting the churches of the Apostles
how to live what to do what not to do
the sins to avoid the virtues to
cultivate how to treat one another how
to Worship in church so this gives you
an idea of how the churches of the
Apostles worshiped during the time of
the Apostles the sins they were to
condemn and the virtues they were to
cultivate did you know that in this
manual you
find the didic condemning abortion and
pedophilia
PTI
PTI you want me to show
that you want me to show you where it
condemns abortion and pedophilia puras
showing you that they would have stoned
Muhammad burned him at the stake well
the Christians couldn't do that at that
time okay here you go here's the
document you got the link right Zack
Mercer free of charge here's the
document oh sorry about that here's the
document free of
charge all right watch here so it is a
manual of correct practice so you go
here here you go chapter the second
command gross inment and the second
commandment of the teaching you shall
not commit murder you shall not commit
adultery you shall not commit
perti that means you will not sleep with
children boys or
girls you shall not commit fornication
you shall not steal you shall not
practice magic you shall not practice
witchcraft you shall not murder Child by
abortion nor kill that which is
begotten see
it guys see it
you see it
there here you have explicit
condemnation from a first century
document written to the churches of the
Apostles telling you what the apostles
commanded Christians to do not to
do right you shall not murder a child by
abortion nor kill that which is begotten
now you're also going to be shown
how they worshiped on Sunday how they
fasted how they prayed and that they
would confess their sins on the first
day of the week here let's go now
Protestants you got a damn problem if
this is written to the churches of the
Apostles when the apostles are alive and
this tells you what the apostles taught
their Christians to do and what not to
do and here you find that the apostles
were telling Christians when they gather
to break bread observe the Eucharist
they are to confess their sins
Protestants you have no continuity with
the churches of the Apostles here it is
chapter 14 Christian Assembly on the
Lord's day but every Lord's Day gather
yourselves together no notice not
Sabbath sabbatarians Lord's day Sunday
break bread giving thanks after having
confessed your transgressions that your
sacrifice may be pure so that tells you
they would gather to observe Eucharist
and confess their sins but let no one
that is at variance with his fellow come
together you until they be reconciled
that your sacrifice may not be Prof
profane and here did is quoting Matthew
showing you that Matthew was already
written for this is what I'm quotes
Matthew earlier I'm sorry like here here
it's quoting Malachi 111 Malachi 1614
but the document I meant to say quotes
Matthew showing that Matthew is already
written like here Matthew 18 as you have
it in the gospel sorry as you have it in
the gospel and what Gospel Matthew 18:15
to1
17 right and here it quotes Malachi
11614 being fulfilled in churches among
the Nations throughout the world where
the Gentiles would gather on the Lord's
day to offer God a pure sacrifice
meaning the Eucharist for this is that
which was spoken by Lord in every place
and time offered to me a pure sacrifice
for I a great king says the Lord and my
name is wonderful among the Nations now
watch why here again Matthew 10:10
see fill of Illusions to new test
writings particularly the gospel of
Matthew here's why I repeat the Lord's
Prayer watch you ready here's
why I repeat the Lord's
Prayer chapter8 and chapter 7 let's read
chapter eight first you with me so
far here's why I repeat and by the way
go watch the session I did with lisis
Dion on the diday it's on my channel and
then watch the streams I did on the
diday it's not the first time you see
why I got to repeat things over and over
again because even those who been with
me for a while forget these things you
can't forget them here is what the
Christians did
under the authority of the
Apostles right under the authority of
the
Apostles here's what the Christians were
told by the apostles to
do to
do what me there to
do if this was written to the churches
in the time of the Apostles and the
apostles still alive that means these
are the Commandments of the Apostles to
their churches
see
it we got it now watch here chapter 8
but let not your fast be with the
Hypocrites see alluding to Matthew 6:16
for they fast on the second and fifth
day of the week if you don't know what
the second fifth day of the week happen
to be they fast on Monday and Thursday
and we find a rabbi tradition that says
the Jews fasted in Monday and Thursday I
even wrote an article I even wrote an
article
showing that Muhammad and the Traditions
attributed to him would also fast Monday
and Thursday and imitation of the
Jews imitation of the
Jews okay do you know that so Muhammad
is a hypocrite according to the commands
of the Lord Jesus Christ because he's
fasting like the Hypocrites Monday and
Thursday I I have an article and I
should do a session on it so when do
Christians fast now if you have been
following me you would know this already
but creatures repetition we need to hear
something repetitively until we come
second nature the churches at the time
apostles were commanded to fast on
Wednesday and Friday you see why
Assyrian Church of these Orthodox and
Catholic all of you have this in common
all the ancient churches
fast on Wednesday and Friday the
Assyrian
Church the Roman Catholic Church the
Orthodox Church whether Oriental or
Eastern you all have this in common even
though you're in Schism which means that
this practice that you have in common
was already being observed before the
Schism broke out since the Assyrian
church was condemned and ostracized in
the fifth century that means this
practice must have been Universal before
the fifth century and look how old it is
it comes from time the apostles but fast
on the fourth day and the preparation
day now do your math the fourth day is
Wednesday the preparation day is the day
that the Jews would prepare for Sabbath
that's
Friday do you see where you get it
from you got it from the apostles the
apostles told their churches you fast
Wednesdays and Fridays
you see
it right there
folks right
there now why do we say the Lord's
Prayer here's why neither pray as
Hypocrites but as the Lord commanded in
his gospel notice again Gospel Matthew
primarily but also found a Luke how are
you supposed to pray and how many times
look at how many
times Our Father who are in heaven
Hallowed Be Your Name Your Kingdom Come
your will be done as in heaven so on
Earth give us today our daily needful
bread forgive us our debts as we also
forgive our debtors bring us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil one
or evil for yours is the power and the
glory forever how many times Thrice in
the day thus prayed pray this three
times a day but hold on don't they know
the gospel of Matthew because that's
where they're referring to it's
referencing the gospel of
Matthew and that's where Jesus says in
Matthew 6 do not be like the pagans and
pray utterly useless prayers vain
babblings repeated prayer that are vain
useless so if repeating prayers comes
under the category vain babbling then
why are they telling me repeat the
Lord's Prayer three times a day because
that's not the meaning of Jesus in
Matthew you Bible
butchers repeating a prayer that is not
vain repeating a prayer that is
Meaningful repeating a prayer that is
full of spiritual
meat is not vain babbling but it is a
necessary tool to discipline yourself
spiritually but you see how many times
three times you see how I do the Lord's
Prayer with you guys what about baptism
and then we're GNA go into shid Lewis so
I just want you to know why I begin with
the Lord's Prayer and why I do the sign
of the cross the way I do do we get it
now do we get it
now we got it now
right all right now
here you see how disconnected you are
Protestants from the ancient Church how
disconnected you are from all this Rich
spiritual Heritage because your churches
do not encourage you to study the works
of the early Christians writings not
found in the New Testament Cannon like
the deday or the Epistle of Barnabas or
the letter of Clement of Rome to the
Corinthians or arus you're disconnected
from your spiritual forebears and your
spiritual ancestors
your
heritage see
that chapter seven concerning baptism
and concerning baptism baptize this way
having first said all these things
baptize into the name of the father and
of the son of the Holy Spirit ouch and
Living Water find Living Water like a
lake or you
know a something but if you have not
living water baptize into other water
and if not if you cannot cold and warm
but if you have not either pour out
water Thrice three times see once for
the father once for the son once for the
Holy Spirit upon the head into the name
of the Father and Son and Holy Spirit
wow so they even tell you you baptize
into the name of the father and the son
Holy Spirit three times for the father
son Holy
Spirit right but before the baptism let
the baptizer The Fast and the baptize
and whatever others can you shall order
the baptize to fast one or two days
before now notice three times right
Thrice once for the father once for the
son once for the spirit similarly why
the Lord's Prayer three times in honor
of the Father Son and Holy Spirit seeing
a pattern
here we get the
pattern that's just to explain why I say
the Lord's Prayer and do the sign of the
cross the way I do